[Music]
what would you give to have perfect
eyesight a faster metabolism
to be a few inches taller or more
muscular for most of history we've had
to deal with the genetic hand we've been
dealt and a lot of times that's not much
fun genetic disorders diseases and
inadequacies have plagued our species
for thousands of years but what if we
could change all that the answer may be
closer than we think after a quarter of
a million years of slow natural
evolution humanity's on the cusp of
having the ability to edit the very
building blocks of our being in the past
few decades we've developed tools that
help doctors and expecting parents to
anticipate any serious health conditions
their child may have such as hereditary
diseases and Down syndrome to some
people these tests already raise ethical
red flags as in many cases especially
outside the United States the majority
of women choose to terminate their
pregnancy if the warning signs of Down
syndrome are detected as our technology
advances we'll be able to move from
detection of these conditions to removal
the first step down the road to
so-called designer babies the hope or
concern is that soon enough we'll
graduate from selecting out the bad
genes to selecting in more favorable
ones this is where many people begin to
cry eugenics and advocate extreme
caution most people would probably agree
that eliminating diseases like
Huntington's or quality of life
disabilities like poor eyesight would be
a good thing and some even suspect that
not editing out these genes would
constitute an ethical failure in the
future but what about giving your child
a leg up on the competition by
sprinkling in traits like increased
height or musical proficiency or
above-average intelligence while the
technology to do this is on its way
we're not there just yet and it's
expected to be very expensive at least
at first you might think well if you've
got the money for it and it's legal why
not you're just giving your child the
best shot at a successful life consider
the following scenario a wealthy couple
decide they want to enhance their baby's
genes
the average woman typically has 15 eggs
extracted for an in-vitro fertilization
procedure those 15 potential children
will likely differ in IQ by about 20 to
30 points the parents will be able to
select the child or children with
superior intelligence to carry to term
doesn't seem like that big of
on the surface but what happens when the
top 10% of society can afford the
procedure but the rest of the population
can't now you have a society divided not
only by the rapidly increasing wage gap
but also by a new intelligence gap with
wealthy children being far more likely
to succeed than the 90 percent below
them this would further stratify our
world into the haves and have-nots with
modified people only marrying and
reproducing with other Modifieds thus
keeping their gene pool more desirable
the solution for this type of situation
would be to make genetic modification
accessible to all people giving everyone
the ability to at least screen out
disease and disabilities like poor
eyesight but when we begin to dabble in
aesthetic or additive modifications we
get to the real dilemma of genetic
engineering just because we can do
something doesn't necessarily mean we
should do it
first comes the issue of deciding what
this perfect human would look like if we
learned anything from Germany during
World War two it's that when one group
dictates what features are best it can
cause some serious problems when parents
can start designing their ideal babies
like a piece of custom furniture there's
a real danger that people will become
competitive adding modifications in a
never-ending quest to build the ultimate
human child then of course there's the
fact that our technology is rarely
infallible what happens when a couple
orders a six foot four Greek god of a
child and he only grows up to be six
foot one could they demand a refund
would they feel cheated out of the
product they ordered how would their
child feel about being considered
inferior and how would society treat him
then there's the international angle
China is already known for its
questionable social engineering
practices such as limiting families to
one child and taking children away from
their parents to be enrolled in Olympic
training schools in an attempt to build
future champions it doesn't take much
imagination to assume that in a country
like that
genetic modification would be seen as a
very good thing parents wouldn't have to
worry about their one child being
insufficient they could order a smart
strong handsome male who would grow up
to take care of his parents just like
they'd always wanted Olympic training
schools would be packed with modified
children suited to each event greater
lung capacity and endurance for distance
runners a smaller leaner built for
gymnasts longer limbs for swimmers when
other countries use genetic modification
to gain a competitive edge whether in
sports or other more serious
applications what
are the rest of us to do it would be
harmful to allow ourselves to be made
non-competitive but what would it cost
to keep up it would be expensive of
course but extreme genetic engineering
may also cost us some of our humanity
and of course there's the potential for
unforeseen health consequences to arise
and modify children DNA is incredibly
complex and many traits aren't simply a
one gene switch what happens when we
accidentally negate a gene that protects
against the disease we have no
experience with tinkering with systems
we don't fully understand is a good way
to end up in big trouble at the end of
the day we have some important questions
to consider when the technology is
widely available will we have an ethical
responsibility to modify our children to
prevent disease or disability or is that
just a part of being human let us know
your thoughts in the comments below you
may have noticed second thought has a
shiny new logo if you like the look of
it come check out our new merch store
and preorder a t-shirt or vinyl stickers
they'll be shipping in about three weeks
so now's your chance to be the cool kid
on the block and get them first as an
added bonus just for being awesome the
first 50 people to visit standard TV /
second thought will get 10% off their
entire order that includes purchases
from some of our other favorite creators
- like Wendover productions real
engineering and crypts cos act so be
sure to visit our merch store using the
link below and get 10% off your order
today remember to subscribe if you
haven't already
smash that Bell and check out these
videos next as always thanks for
watching and we'll see you next week